Guten Tag, mein Name ist Uccak, ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnese-Gespräch durchführen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich.
Danke, bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, okay?
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Herman Hofmeister.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam buchstabieren?
H-E-R-M-A-N, mein Name, H-O-F-M-E-I-S-T-E-R, Hofmeister.
Okay, Herr Hofmeister, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
3. Oktober 1969.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1 Meter 78.
Und wie schwer sind Sie zuzeit?
76.
Okay, danke für die Informationen, Herr Hofmeister. Was kann ich für Sie tun? Was Schweres haben Sie im Moment?
Ja, Doktor, ich habe Brustbeinschmerzen.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Seit anderthalb Wochen, Doktor.
Okay, können Sie bitte diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben? Also sind Sie eher drückend, stechen, dumpf?
Ja, die Schmerzen sind drückend und dumpf, ja.
Okay. Sind diese Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Plötzlich aufgetreten, Doktor.
Okay, strahlen diese Schmerzen irgendwohin aus?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, nein.
Aber meine Schmerzen sind hinter dem Brustbein, Doktor.
Okay, also fühlen Sie sich ein enger Gefühl in der Brust?
Ja, ich fühle mich ein enger Gefühl.
Leiden Sie unter Luftnot oder Husten?
Ich habe keine Husten unter Luftnot, nein.
Okay. Herr Hofmeister, haben Sie früher einige Beschwerden gehabt?
Nein.
Oder haben Sie dagegen ein Medikament eingenommen?
Ich habe keine Medikamente eingenommen, nein.
Okay. Waren Sie wegen dieser Beschwerden bei einem anderen Arzt gewesen?
Nein.
Okay. Darf ich fragen, wie stark sind diese Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10?
Die Schmerzen würde ich als 9 von 10 auf einer Schmerzskala, Doktor.
Okay. Herr Hofmeister, das ist eine starke Schmerzen.
Ja, ich glaube.
Soll ich Ihnen eine Schmerzmittei geben oder können Sie diese Schmerzen noch ein bisschen bis Ende des Gesprächs aushalten?
Ja, ich habe Geduld sein, Doktor.
Okay. Ich werde mich beeilen, okay?
Okay.
Also Sie haben eine Hinterbrustschmerzen seit ein und halb Wochen?
Ja, ein Wochen.
Okay. Alles klar.
Haben Sie Herzrasen oder Herzklopfen?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Okay. Herr Hofmeister, Sie haben eine Brustschmerzen, deswegen möchte ich das Anamnestgespräch unterbrechen.
Also ich möchte Ihren Vitalparameter überwachen, okay?
Dann können wir das Anamnestgespräch weitermachen.
Herr Oberarzt, ich möchte das Anamnestgespräch unterbrechen.
Der Patient leidet unter Brustbeinschmerzen.
Also das kann ein Myokadinfakt sein, deswegen möchte ich die Vitalparameter überwachen und eine LKG schreiben.
Aber jetzt bin ich in der Prüfung und ich möchte das Anamnestgespräch weitermachen. Darf ich?
Ja, bitte.
Danke.
Herr Hofmeister, bleiben Sie unter Sodbrennen oder Sauerstoff?
Nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt, Doktor. Aber meine Appetit ist nicht gut, Doktor. Meine Appetit ist sehr schlecht. Und ich fühle mich oft kraftlos.
Okay. Herr Hofmeister, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit unwirklich abgenommen?
Ja, in den letzten sechs Monaten habe ich ungefähr sechs Kilo abgenommen, Doktor.
Okay. Herr Hofmeister, haben Sie Schluckstörungen?
Ja, ich kann kaum schlucken, Doktor. Deshalb habe ich in den letzten Tagen nur Suppe gegessen und etwas getrunken.
Und können Sie nicht mehr festes Nahrungsmittel schlucken, richtig?
Ja, richtig. Und vor etwa einer Woche habe ich ein bis zwei Mal Blut erbrochen, Doktor.
Wann war das, Herr Hofmeister? Das letzte Mal?
Vor etwa einer Woche.
Okay. Und momentan haben Sie kein Problem, richtig?
Ja, momentan kein Problem. Aber früher habe ich zwei Mal Blut erbrochen.
Okay. Und haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang? Also, ich meine, haben Sie einen schwarzen Stuhl bemerkt?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Oder haben Sie Blut im Stuhl bemerkt?
Nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt, Doktor.
Okay. Alles klar. Herr Hofmeister, darf ich fragen, haben Sie ein Gefühl, wie Sie eine fremde...
Was war das? Ja. Okay. Haben Sie ein Gefühl, ob Sie eine...
Was, Doktor? Ich habe nicht verstanden.
Ja, also ich möchte sagen, Herr Hofmeister, haben Sie ein Gefühl, dass Sie ein...
Hab ich schon vergessen. Ach so, ja. Also, haben Sie ein Gefühl, dass Sie einen fremden Körper am Hals haben? Ich meine.
Ja, ich habe nicht bemerkt, Doktor.
Okay, alles klar.
Ist Ihnen übel? Ja, oder... Ja, ist Ihnen übel? Im Moment meine ich.
Jetzt nicht, aber etwa eine Woche hatte ich übel und habe gesagt, erbrochen, ja.
Ja, okay.
Aber ich habe auch häufiges aufgestochen, dass es ungenem riecht, ja.
Meinen Sie, haben Sie ungewöhnlich ein Mundgeruch bemerkt, oder?
Ja, ja, ja. Richtig, ja. Und häufig aufgestochen, ja.
Aufgestochen haben Sie auch, ja? Ja.
Und leiden Sie unter Sodbrennen?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Okay. Haben Sie Fieberstaffrost oder Nachtschweiß?
Nein.
Okay. Ist alles in Ordnung bei Ihnen?
Ja. Normalerweise muss ich oft auf die Toilette gehen, weil ich so krank bin, Doktor.
Aber ich habe keine Schmerzen beim Wasserlassen oder Wasserveränderung oder...
Aber ich muss viele mal, besonders nachts, ja.
Okay. Wie oft müssen Sie auf die Toilette gehen, in der Nacht besonders?
In der Nacht zwei oder viermal, ja.
Okay, alles klar. Also, schlafen Sie gut?
Nein. Ich fühle mich oft kraftlos und wegen der Schmerzen kann ich auch schlecht schlafen, Doktor, ja.
Okay. Haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen? Oder beide?
Ja, beide. Ja, ich habe gesagt, ich muss viele mal in die Toilette gehen und ich habe starke Schmerzen.
Deswegen schlafe ich nicht gut, Doktor, ja.
Ja, Sie haben recht. Okay, alles klar.
Herr Hofmeister, sind Sie vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten geimpft?
Ja, ja. Ich bin vollständig geimpft, ja. So wie viermal gegen Covid, ja.
Okay. Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie an Zuckerkrankheiten leiden. Seit wann?
Seit ungefähr 25 Jahren, ja.
Und was nehmen Sie dagegen ein? Ich meine ein Medikament?
Ich nehme dagegen mit vor mir 850 mg morgens und abends ein.
Okay. Sonst noch etwas? Haben Sie andere Erkrankungen?
Ja, außerdem habe ich einen Bluthochdruck, Doktor. Seit wann?
Seit 10 Jahren. Und nehmen Sie ein Medikament dagegen ein?
Ja, ich nehme morgens, am 1. April, einmal. Aber wie ist die Dosis? Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Okay. Wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Ja, mein Hausarzt ist Herr Fischer.
Okay. Herr Hofmeister, ich werde Ihren Hausarzt kontaktieren für diese Details. Okay?
Okay. Okay, danke. Okay, sonst? Haben Sie noch irgendwelche anderen Erkrankungen?
Nein. Okay. Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, Doktor. Vor einem Jahr wurde mir die Linse am linken Auge ausgetauscht.
und vor etwa einem Jahr war ich wegen einem Nervenzusammenbruch in einer
Nervenklinik in Behandlung. Okay, alles klar. Herr Hofmeister, nehmen Sie regelmäßig
den Bedarf außer genannten Medikamenten, irgendwelche anderen Medikamente ein?
Nein, Doktor. Okay. Haben Sie Allergie gegen irgendwelche Nahrungsmittel, Pflanzen, Medikamente?
Ja, ich habe Allergien gegen Meere, Früchte und Fisch.
Wie ersetzt sich diese Allergien? Das äußerst sich durch Atemnot und
Hautausschlag, Doktor. Und Juckreis. Beide Allergien, ja? Ja, ja. Okay. Herr Hofmeister,
rauchen Sie? Ich rauche nicht, Doktor. Haben Sie früher geraucht? Nein. Trinken Sie
regelmäßig Alkohol? Nicht regelmäßig, aber ich trinke nur selten mal ein Glas Wein am
Wochenende oder ein Ferain. Okay. Und bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich,
das ist eine rote Frage. Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen? Ich habe
keinen Kontakt mit Drogen, nein. Okay, super. Leiden Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen,
von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Schlaganfall oder Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja, meine Mutter leidet auch an Zuckerkrankheit, ja. Und mein Vater an Demenz. Bei der Leber
in Altenheim, ja. Okay, haben Sie Geschwister? Ja, mein Bruder ist vor sechs Jahren am Magenkrebs
gestorben. Okay. Wie ist Ihr Familienstand? Ich bin verheiratet. Haben Sie Kinder? Ich
habe fünf Kinder, ja. Sind Ihre Kinder gesund? Nein, mein Onkel hatte... Nein, Entschuldigung.
Ja, ja, alle sind gesund, ja. Okay. Wohnen Sie mit Ihrer Familie? Ja. Okay, was ist Sie von Beruf,
Herr Hofmeister? Ich bin Hausmann. Okay. Herr Hofmeister, würden Sie etwas über Ihren Onkel
sagen? Ja, ja, mein Onkel hatte Nierenkrebs, Doktor, ja. Okay, alles klar. Das waren meine
Fragen. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich? Ja, Doktor,
was habe ich? Ich habe viel Angst. Während unserer Aufnahmegespräch sind Sie umgebrechen
und Sie haben mir eine EKG geschrieben. Ich habe Herzkrankheit oder... Ja, also Herr Hofmeister,
machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen. Ich wusste das Anamnesegespräch unterbrechen,
weil Sie eine Brustschmerzen haben. Ja, also ich habe eine EKG geschrieben, aber alles gut beim
EKG. Also ich vermute, dass Sie ein Problem mit der Speiseröhre haben. Aber es ist zu früh,
etwas genau zu sagen. Ich werde Sie zuerst körperlich untersuchen, dann werde ich Ihnen
Blut abnehmen und ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen. Sobald die Ergebnisse da sind,
werde ich Ihnen die weitere Information mitteilen. Okay? Okay, ich möchte gerne wissen, ob ich in
Krankenhaus bleibe oder kann ich nach Hause gehen? Herr Hofmeister, ein paar Stunden müssen Sie
sicherlich bei uns bleiben, damit wir die Diagnose bestätigen können und eine Therapie
einleiten können. Aber wenn wir etwas Auffälliges finden, kann es auch passieren,
dass Sie ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus bleiben sollen. Ja? Okay, danke schön Doktor. Ich
warte auf Sie. Danke. Sehr gerne. Bitte nehmen Sie Platz und warten Sie mal. Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Okay? Danke schön. Bis gleich. Bitte. Heute haben wir es geschafft, Haydar. Ja,
Herr Doktor. Wenn Sie keine Zigarre oder so trinken, wenn die Kinder nicht sehr
gesund sind, dann... Wenn sie nicht gesund sind, dann trinken sie. Ja, ja, ja.
Schönen guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt. Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen und ich würde
gerne über ihn berichten. Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich? Ja, bitte. Danke schön. Herr
Herrmann Hofmeister ist 56 Jahre alt, 1 Meter 78 groß und 76 Kilogramm schwer. Herr Hofmeister
stellte sich heute bei uns seit ein und halb Wochen bestehender retrosternale Schmerzen vor.
Der Patienten zufolge seien die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten und mit der Zeit schlimmer
geworden. Die Schmerzen seien drückend und dumpf und die Schmerzen würden nirgendwo hin
ausstrahlen. Der Patient berichtete über Engelgefühl in der Brust und Halitosis
und Aufstoßen. Die Schmerzintensität wurde auf eine Schmerzskala mit 9 von 10 bewertet
und der Patient habe dagegen kein Medikament eingenommen. Die Fragen nach... Entschuldigung,
ja. Und der Patient erwähnte eine Gewichtsabnahme von 6 Kilogramm innerhalb von 6 Monaten und er
leidet unter Appetitlosigkeit. Außerdem klagte er über Fatigue und Dysphagie. In der
letzter Zeit kann er nur Flüssigkeiten schlucken und er erwähnte, dass er in den
letzten Wochen zweimal Hematemesis leide. Die Fragen nach Melena, Hämodekezi und Globus
Historicus wurden verneint. Bei der vegetativen Anamnese seien die Folienden bekannt.
Nuktyrie 3-4 Mal in der Nacht und schmerzbedingte Insomnie in Form von Einschlafstörungen und
Durchschlafstörungen. Er sei vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und 4-mal Covid-Infektion
geimpft. An Vorerkrankungen nannte er seit 25 Jahren bestehenden Diabetes Melitus und seit
10 Jahren bestehende alte Hypertonie. Er nehme Metformin 850 Milligramm morgens und abends,
11 April morgens ein. Die Dosierung von 11 April sollte geklärt werden. Vor einem Jahr
sei er eine Lenzimplantation. Vor einem Jahr sei bei ihm eine linkseitige Lenzimplantation
durchgeführt worden und vor einem Jahr habe er einen Nervenzusammenbruch gelitten,
die in der Klinik behandelt worden sei. Er hatte Allergie gegen mehr Früchte und Fisch,
die sich durch Dyspnoe, Exanthin und Puritus äußern. Nikotinkonsum und Drogenkonsum wurden
verneint. Er trinke ein Glas Wein am Wochenende. In der Familienanalyse gab er an, dass der
Vater an der Lenz leidet und die Mutter leidet an Diabetes Melitus. Seine Eltern wohnen in einem
Alteheim. Er habe einen Bruder, der vor sechs Jahren an Magenkarzinum verstorben sei und
seine Onkel leiden an Nierenkarzinum. Er sei verheiratet und habe fünf gesunde Kinder und
er wohne mit seiner Familie. Er sei Hausmann von Beruf. Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf
eine Esophaguskarzinum aus, da der Patient typische Symptome dafür aufweist. Der
Patient leidet unter Dysphagie und retrochternale Schmerzen, Gewichtsabnahme von sechs Kilogramm
innerhalb von sechs Monaten, chronischer Fatigue und zweimal Hämathemesis. Diese Symptome
sprechen für eine Esophaguskarzinum. Als Differenzdiagnosen kommen Magenkarzinum,
Mekadvertikel, Akelazia in Betracht. Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen,
würde ich zunächst bei den Patienten die Vitaparameter überwachen und eine körperliche
Untersuchung durchführen. Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob eine
Hautfarbeveränderung gern, wie z.B. Palore, vergrößerte Lymphknoten vorhanden sind und
zusätzlich ist eine Labouruntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnostik zu
gewährleisten. Dabei würde ich Blutbild, CAP, BSG, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Tumormakels,
Elektrolyten bestimmen lassen. Danach würde ich eine Esophagosophage-Gastroskopie
durchführen, um die Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen und eine Gewebeprobe zu entnehmen.
Darüber hinaus würde ich eine Abdominalsonographie fernlassen, um die möglichen Metastasen
genau zu beurteilen. Und gegebenenfalls würde ich eine CT des Thorax und CT des Abdomens
durchführen, um die möglichen Metastasen genau zu überprüfen. Und gegebenenfalls
würde ich auch eine PCT durchführen, um die möglichen Metastasen am ganzen Körper
genau zu beurteilen. Und ich würde eine Röntgen-Kontrast-Untersuchung durchführen,
um die mögliche Stenose oder Verengung der Speiseröhre des Esophages zu genau
beurteilen. Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten stationär
aufnehmen und ich würde einen Venösenzugang legen und ich würde Flüssigkeitzufuhr,
Analgetika verabreichen. Ich würde einen chirurgischen Konsil anfordern, um die
Therapie des Patienten zu optimieren. Wenn der Kacidom in lokalisiertes Studium ist,
würde ich eine Mukosektomie empfehlen oder ich würde eine Ösophagus-Ösophagektomie
und Magenhochzug empfehlen. Wenn es eine Metastasen gibt, würde ich eine Chemotherapie
empfehlen. Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit den
geplanten Untersuchungen fortfahren. Herr Kollege, Sie haben gesagt, ich habe
ein EKG geschrieben. Können Sie uns das EKG aufklären? Ja, gerne. Ich werde Sie über
das EKG aufklären. Das EKG ist eine Untersuchung, mit der wir die elektrische Aktivität des
Herzens aufzeichnen können. Diese Untersuchung hilft uns, die Durchblutstörungen, Herzrhythmstörungen
und andere Herzkrankheiten genau zu erkennen. Dazu werden mehrere Elektroden auf der Brust
und auf den Armen und Beinen befestigt. Diese Elektroden messen die elektrische Aktivität
des Herzens und zeigen sie wie Kurven auf einem Monitor. Diese Untersuchung ist sowohl
als auch schmerzfrei. Diese Untersuchung dauert ca. einige Minuten. Es gibt keine
Komplikationen oder Kontraindikationen. Dafür benötigt der Patient keine spezielle
Vorbereitung. Der Patient soll ruhig auf dem Rücken liegen. Nach der Untersuchung
gibt es keine Anschränkungen und der Patient kann den Alltag wie gewohnt fortsetzen.
Würden Sie in diesem Fall eine Echokardiografie durchführen?
Ja, wir können eine Echokardiografie durchführen, um die Klappenstörungen
und Herzwandstörungen genau zu beurteilen. Der Patient leidet unter Brustschmerzen und
bei dieser Situation sollen wir eine EKG schreiben und auch eine Echokardiografie durchführen.
Würden Sie in diesem Fall eine PTCA durchführen?
Der Patient leidet unter Brustschmerzen, aber ich vermute, dass der Patient an
Sophagus carcinum leidet und wir haben eine EKG geschrieben. Wenn es ein Problem mit der
EKG gibt, können wir eine PTCA durchführen. Aber wenn es kein Problem mit der EKG gibt,
dann sollen wir keine PTCA durchführen. Was können wir mit Hilfe einer PET-CT in diesem Fall
erhalten? Wir können mit Hilfe einer PET-CT die Metastasen genau beurteilen.
Also diese Untersuchung hilft uns, die Tumore und die Metastase genau zu beurteilen.
Ist es möglich, in diesem Fall eine Akalasi zu machen?
Ja, Akalasi kommt als eine Differenziadiagnose bei diesem Fall. Deswegen können wir eine
Kontrastmitteluntersuchung durchführen, um die mögliche Pathologie wie zum Beispiel
Akalasi genau zu beurteilen. Wie behandeln wir diese Patienten?
Zuerst sollen wir eine Gewebeprobe entnehmen während der Oesophagoskopie. Dann werden wir
diese Gewebeprobe zur histologischen Untersuchung. Dann werden wir das Studium des Patienten
genau feststellen. Wenn der Katsynom, ein lokalisiertes Katsynom ist, dann können wir
eine Mukosektomie während der Oesophagoskopie durchführen. Aber wenn der Katsynom ein fortschrittener
Katsynom ist, dann können wir eine Oesophagektomie und Magenhochzug durchführen und auch
Lymphadenektomie durchführen. Und wenn es eine Metastase gibt, sollen wir eine Chemotherapie
bei den Patienten anordnen. Was empfehlen Sie nach der Behandlung den Patienten?
Ja, regelmäßige Hausarztkontrolle sind sehr wichtig. Der Patient rauchen nicht. Es gibt
kein Risikofaktor außer Bruder. Der Bruder hat vor sechs Jahren an Magenkrebs verstorben.
Der Patient soll regelmäßig den Hausarzt besuchen und die Tumormarker kontrollieren lassen.
Würden Sie in diesem Fall Abdomenzonographie durchführen?
Ja, Abdomenzonographie ist eine wichtige Untersuchung bei diesen Patienten, damit wir die Metastase
von inneren Bauchorganen feststellen. Wie zum Beispiel Lebermetastase oder Nierenmetastase.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Okay, Herr Kollegen, ich gratuliere Sie. Bitte gehen Sie auf unser Infodesk und nehmen Sie Ihre Zertifikat.
Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg für Ihre Arbeitsweg.
Vielen Dank Herr Abbas. Sie sind sehr nett. Dankeschön.